so I was with ca for a long time and
then 5 years ago I started my own
speaking bureau Vayner speakers oh wow
so if you're looking to make you know I
can make you some money on the sauce I
can make you some money on the speaking
there you go yeah you have a story this
is turning out to be a really good you
no you know I'm I'm I'm fascinated with
your you said you have a very big
speaking fee yes but that wasn't always
the case does that come with a
self-worth thing or like no supply and
demand of of of it's a great question do
I think people whether they're doing
standup comedy whether they're doing
anything you know cutting hair you can
cut it for 12 bucks you can cut it for
50 like sure there's that game of do you
know what you're asking for but the
market is the market like when I first
started 34 years old really speaking
well I had pretty good confidence I'm
like I really think I'm good but the
market hadn't said that I was worth what
I'm worth now okay so I think it's just
supplying to me un you know speaking is
funny and personal appearance is funny
for the human and you've been through
this and for people who go through it or
think about it it seems crazy that you
could be compensated so well for a short
period of time but in reality there's
something happening on the back end so I
can be like oh my God I'm getting
[__] flown to Madrid and I'm going to
speak for an hour and it's I can't
believe the economics I'm making it's
not like the world is Puffy ideological
yay yay the organizers of that event in
Spain are making money on the fact that
I'm there sure you know and so it's it's
very much supply and demand self for's a
good question do I believe a lot of
people listening right now mowing lungs
cutting hair public speaking Super
Famous not known at all doing a service
business do I think most people don't
know how to ask for a little more money
the next time to keep upping their fee
yes I do and I'm glad you asked that
question um when I go do a podcast like
this I'm like okay this is [__] an
epic show with icons I'm going to come
on we're going to talk about our subject
matter but like if I can leave in like
three to seven people hear one little
tidbit and all whatever the [__] we chop
up at and it becomes a good thing for
them like the thought that somebody
right now actually that does something
he's like yeah [__] and like they charge
a 100 bucks for whatever the [__] we're
talking about right babysitting 12 bucks
an hour and tomorrow the neighbor goes
how much are you and you're like $15 an
hour because you listen to this and they
say yes then we had a good [__]
podcast that's great people will say you
know I know and by the way people say no
and don't change your price back to $12
an hour get 10 Nos and then you're like
okay I'm delusional my big thing is get
10 NOS before you go back down too many
people like are scared to go up try one
time someone says no and they're like
see [__] Gary I was always 12 yeah
you get what you paid for it yeah I'm
glad that you said that too because when
I initially was saying you know what I
started to say I was uh going to express
a sensitivity that uh speaking to my
audience you know about like like I
wanted to make it relatable to people
and you just did that for me see
honestly no [__] like I've got lots
of passions but and lots of things I
want to talk about but you know I'm very
selective of what I do and when I do it
I always think it's only about them like
I don't need people skipping this
podcast for you I don't want to [__] you
up I don't want people to be like that
suck that's not for me if you can't make
it contextual and relatable to who's
actually going to listen then what the
[__] are we doing here right like I'm
more than capable of trying to build my
own audience on my channels I think when
you go into someone's home you take off
the shoes you know what I mean like to
me the only thing I'm thinking about
right now is how to respect y'all and
more importantly even more than you is
your audience and so like look take me
wherever you think I can bring value but
the good news is like I'm aware of y'all
and I'm a fan and like I I like and more
importantly like cool I'm a business man
but like like I'm also a human being
like what do you think me and my buddies
did in Jersey in the 80s and 90s dumb
[__] and like you guys are legends to us
they're like oh [__] all the dumb [__]
we were doing is like real like that so
like this this is fun to be with you
cool I love it thank you for that um
what's the probably very blurry line
like uh what Viner media yes um an ad
agency and a production company yes God
so we have a production company you can
pull this one up Eva noad Eva Noam how
do you remember all these names it's two
separate words they'll probably it's Eva
space noad Dam nosad dam Eva space here
we go there we go it's there
um so this is Madison a spelled
backwards ah um this is our production
company for our commercials in New York
in New York and la and I own this as
well this is part of Vayner X Vayner
media is the agency even Noam is the
production company now to your point the
world you grew up in production was
heavy like big [__] it was real and so
our commercials are Super Bowl we do
here our agency as the creative
Department they're also producing actual
social media ads so that's the twist
that we did to the industry forever 70
years you had an ad agency that came up
with the ideas and then that's what you
got paid for and then there was a
production company that would make this
merch Madness by Lil baty B that we did
for Fanatics we still do that as you can
see here with iaos Sadam and Vayner
media but inside of Vayner media the ad
firm everybody in Creative also makes
social media creative and that was the
Twist and that's how we changed the
industry is one of your uh
contemporaries are your Rivals at um
Vayner media a company called
sharability are you familiar with them
yes I think that got brought up to me
the other day um um maybe um one thing I
don't do it's either my strength or my
weakness I'm almost oblivious to
competition good Blue Ocean strategy
yeah I've heard that as well what is
that it's just like there's no
competition there's no red in the
there's no blood in the Water by the way
I love competition like if you guys were
like let's thumb wrestle I'd get like
super serious right now yeah yeah but
you have the mindset there's like enough
for everybody it's it and by the way if
somebody's like wins something you're
absolutely I don't think that they took
it out of me I by the way that includes
like we're in a pitch right now for
we're not but I'm going to use it
because I love them if we're in to pitch
for New Balance yeah and we're against
droga 5 and sharability and wi and
Kennedy and we're it's four of us and we
lose I'm aware that one of those three
people won mhm but that's the micro in
the macro I'm going to get mine for sure
we're good enough
and honestly weirdly I even like when
other people first of all I kind of
weirdly like losing like I'm like you
know there's a level of like leaning
into your own humility and like you
should never always win and the Merit
and trying to figure out how to get
better at it um but yeah blue ocean
defin for me it's always abundance for
sure it's like nobody's stopping me but
myself if I spend a minute trying to
figure out what everybody else is doing
that's a minute I'm not figuring out the
consumer and I don't have time for that
nonsense do you like shopping on Amazon
I do and good news is sto's butt wipes
for your butthole are available on
Amazon and if you want a real bundle of
a deal you can get sto's hot sauce for
your butthole plus sto's butthole
destroyer and steo butt wipes for your
butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right
now yeah dude